who are you let's just say I'm the boss
the boss you're a baby you were a diaper
you know who else wears diapers
astronauts a NASCAR driver that's called
efficiency Templeton the average toddler
spends what 45 hours a year on the
product I am hot EPIK inspector come one
step closer and I'll illuminate you with
a soft glow and I'll clean your clock Oh
blimey look you've all made an excellent
decision to see this movie you're
clearly shrewd so let me lay this out
for you on March 31st my movie
DreamWorks the boss baby will be coming
out we don't have any talking
candlesticks but if that's a deal
breaker will cram one in there somewhere
[Music]
I think the kid might be on to me yeah
oh yeah look the kids are finally
getting along that's nice I'm on a
mission puppies are women and babies are
losing my job is to find out why now see
if there's someplace around here with
decent sushi I kill for a spicy tuna
roll right about now I will help you
just to get rid of you deal how do we
get back the guard welcome I don't we're
not complaining what's all the racket
did he adorable I've got one for you too
what I can't do this without you would
you make a pretty good clue no literally
I can't reach the doorknob
I've never them filthy really lovely
life
[Music]
what's that cookie down
cookies stopper closer
you